hi this is edmund tran stepping in for
reviewer job gilroy to read his grounded
early access review
now just a note before we start this
review evaluates grounded based
solely on its early access release as of
august 2020.
we plan on reviewing grounded again once
it gets a full 1.0 release in the future
think about your favorite survival games
think back to how they launched
think of their initial public showing if
your favorites are like mine you'll
notice a trend
none of them were very good when they
first launched the general public
subnautica had me on the edge of my seat
at launch but it ran terribly
four years later and its 1.0 build was
one of my favorite games in a year that
included god of war and red dead
redemption 2.
likewise the forest launched a mere
shadow of the terrifying adventure it
would eventually become
no man's sky was near universally
criticized at launch
but it eventually reached its potential
and went beyond
and now grounded from obsidian
entertainment is currently in the early
part of the aforementioned early access
phase and is lacking in many respects
but like the games i just mentioned it
has what feels like the potential to
grow into something much
much greater
a co-op survival game like many others
grounded puts you in the shoes of one of
four tween explorers and challenges you
to live
instead of sending you to a stranded
island or an ocean-covered planet
grounded plonks you in a suburban
backyard the twist
you're one two thousandth your regular
size
you get to live out a situation that is
pulled straight out of things like honey
i shrunk the kids the magic school bus
or anatomy park
and if you have any affinity for those
things getting to take part in the
situation is very cool
you're awakened with no memory of how
you landed in this situation and your
goals are twofold
work out how to return to your normal
size and more pressingly
to survive neither objective is all that
simple
in its current state you can actually
wrap up the story content of grounded in
under 30 minutes once you know what
you're doing and where to go
there's little stopping you from
completing the steps necessary to finish
the game
from there you're able to complete
rudimentary quests and you can continue
to explore and build in the backyard
world
but you won't be achieving any story
goals of course
the story is far from finished in its
current form you aren't
big again after you finish what's
available the rest of it simply hasn't
been implemented yet
that's not surprising other story
focused survival games like subnautica
and the forest
were the same when they launched after a
short period then you're left with
really just one goal
survival survival games are about
priority management
the good ones are a series of checklists
vital tasks for you to tick off each
in-game
day in order to eagerly start the list
of new the next day
but the thrill of playing an outstanding
survival game
comes from the way that priority
management leads to unexpected
storylines
grounded starts off deceptively easy you
need food and water or you'll perish
day one involves working out what is
edible and what isn't
you can eat mushrooms and you can
reliably find water dude dangling from
blades of grass
unfortunately because you're the size of
a lego figure's hand
you discover that mites will try to eat
you suddenly your priorities change
now you need food water and something to
defend yourself
grounded features a great system in the
form of scab os
which helpfully details crafting recipes
unluckily while hunting for the pebblet
sprigs and plant fibers you need to make
a spear you might get stuck in a
spiderweb
and again your priorities change
grounded has those
compelling survival hooks while
progression is superficially tied to the
scanning mechanism wherein you feed
objects into a computer to learn new
recipes
the real growth comes from your own
internalization the better you
understand the world the better you're
able to manage your needs and wants
and that knowledge leads to the ability
to alter your management strategies
even in its larval form grounded
provides you with an array of methods
for negating the pressures of survival
you can build canteens to carry water
and tanks to store it
you can cook food build walls and craft
armor weapons and more
and knowing these things allows you to
adjust your task list further to enhance
efficiency
even when you're a miniature bear grylls
the second to second narrative is
continuously
changing because there's always
something you can't account for just
around the corner
while the map layout is fixed in each
run much of the resource in enemy
placement is not so even when you know
exactly what you're doing
there's an area of inevitability in the
knowledge that things are always just
moments away from going terribly wrong
at one point in a successful run
two giant wolf spiders nasty jumping
beasts about the size of a range rover
compared to my player character
decided to leave their homes and destroy
my group's base we'd done nothing to
provoke the attack and being unable to
defeat two wolf spiders at once
we were forced to simply sit and watch
as our base was demolished
also he thought we were saved from
certain death when two lady beetles
showed up and started attacking the
spiders
and thankfully if you're scared of
spiders the game features a moan to
cater to arachnophobes
what makes survival games special is
that nobody else will have that exact
same story
and grounded nails that emergent element
in a way that's natural and
consequential
it's the same feeling you get when
mutants rage or base in the forest
or when leviathans attack your cyclops
in subnautica
these are common occurrences but the
circumstances surrounding them make them
endearingly personal
what brings grounded back to earth is
the sheer lack of
depth in its priorities the survival
loop in the game as it is right now is
simply too
short too easy to manage and get a
complete hold up
and apart from doing quests for burg l
the helpful grilling robot who marks the
end of the game's current story content
there's little reason to extend your
reach beyond their grasp
in fact in his current form building
giant bases in anything but creative
mode is almost an impossible effort
while the dual wolf spider attack is my
own it's not exactly a rare occurrence
and many players in the community have
spoken about the overly hostile wildlife
and its base wrecking desires
the tapes you find yes audio tapes are a
primary narrative advice
hint at the wildlife suddenly becoming
unusually hostile
so we might eventually find out why the
insects are so aggro until that can be
dealt with though you're generally
better off building your base into a
permanent structure like a soda can
and even then you're only keeping out
the biggest of baddies
and while grounded definitely has plans
to expand the world feels overall
a little small in this early access form
puns aside
the map doesn't feel like it has the
square footage to feel vast
you move around it quickly you jump high
and suffer little 4 damage
and you can even get a dandelion to
allow you to glide the game has a
cartoon adventure vibe
so the arcade style movement makes sense
but the extra speed effectively shrinks
the map
once you come to understand it fully
strangely there's no radial compass in
the game which initially makes finding
your way around
difficult it's easy to get turned around
in the grass stalk forest of some litter
bug's backyard
because it can be tricky to spot any
landmarks and until you get your
bearings and add some trail markers the
only thing that
really slows you down as you bunny hop
across the map is the need to tap
m to work out where you're going
grounded has the foundation needed to
turn into a great survival game
but it has a long way to go yet the
titular term comes from aviation
when a pilot finds themselves for
whatever reason unable to fly
they are grounded it's a pretty apt name
for the current state of obsidian's
foray into the co-op survival genre
but like a balsa wood airplane grounded
sits at the outstretched tension point
of a strong
rubber band it is pure unadulterated
potential energy
and all we can do is sit back and wait
to see if that rubber band snaps
or if the game achieves takeoff i think
it's gonna fly
[Music]
you